bonsoir nous sommes le mardi et 14 juin
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous recevons sur
l'actualité locale avec nos invités mais
également les journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite les titres de
cette édition
retour sur le drame de magnanville hier
un policier sa femme fonctionnaire au
ministère de l'intérieur ont été
assassinés à leur domicile par l'art
aussi à bâle à un attentat revendiqué
par l'état islamique bernard cazeneuve
ministre de l'intérieur était ce matin
dans les yvelines pour apporter son
soutien aux fonctionnaires de police
réaction à suivre dans cette édition les
premières maquettes et des fresques du
vally bull ont été dévoilées ce week-end
une façade d'immeuble vont être décorés
dans ce quartier de 4000 habitants des
sites 2020 et enfin l été approche les
temps pour les étudiants de trouver un
job d'été pourquoi pas devenir un pro de
la brochette le secteur recrute pour la
saison estivale les jeunes motivés dès
l'âge de saison et c'est ce nouvel
attentat qui marquent l'actualité
aujourd'hui hier soir à magnanville
commune proche de mantes la jolie
un commandant de police et son épouse
ont été tuées par un homme se
revendiquant de l'état islamique
le raid a donné l'assaut dans la nuit le
fils du couple âgé de trois ans a été
retrouvée indemne
aujourd'hui c'est la stupeur qui règne
dans les communes de magnanville
mantes-la-jolie encore les mureaux la ou
les victimes résider et travailler
retour sur ce drame avec et mélanie
potier disparition tragique et actes
terroristes
bernard cazeneuve ministre de
l'intérieur a rencontré ce matin les
policiers du commissariat des mureaux
autres c'est ici que travailler le
commandant de police tué hier soir avec
son épouse secrétaire au commissariat de
mantes la jolie par un homme se
revendiquant de l'état islamique
j'ai eu l'occasion d'exprimer aux
policiers
notre immense tristesse toute notre
compassion dans le de leur dire la
solidarité de la république dans toutes
ses forces se rassembler ce qui nous
apporte à nous tous au sein de
l'appareil d'état à la fois la
chancellerie et au ministère de
l'intérieur c'est que nous puissions
faire avancer cette enquête de manière à
mettre hors d'état de nuire d'éventuels
complices à la fois nous sommes tous
choqués choqué bien évidemment ces îles
sont plus choqués encore connue
comme leurs collègues
c'est aussi cette institution
donc c'est vraiment ce que représente
notre public à magnanville commune de
6000 habitants où étaient domiciliés les
victimes
le quartier résidentiel peine à
retrouver sa tranquillité
on est sous le choc tout hélicoptère est
passé au dessus de ma maison donc ça
fait drôle et on habite juste derrière
donc on a vu le défilé de de police de
sapeurs pompiers nous avons toute la
nuit des choqué par par tout ça les
riverains déplacées par les forces de
l'ordre durant la nuit ont réintégré
leur logement la commune a mis en place
une cellule psychologique en lien avec
la préfecture ce matin avec ma première
adjointe et mon équipe municipale et
l'éducation nationale on a mis une
cellule de soutien psychologique auprès
des élèves et de neuf de leurs parents
donc dans les écoles de magnanville je
vais mettre aussi une cellule de soutien
auprès du périscolaire de mon personnel
qui est très choquée parce que le petit
bonhomme
il avait aussi au périscolaire
l'agresseur l'art aussi à bâle a été tué
lors de l'assaut du raid
trois personnes de son entourage sont en
garde à vue une minute de silence en
hommage aux deux fonctionnaires se fera
demain au commissariat des mureaux et de
nombreuses personnalités se sont
exprimées suite à ce drame ils étaient
nombreux à témoigner de leur soutien sur
internet et notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux en france mais également dans
les yvelines comme monseigneur aumônier
de l'évêché de versailles qui apportait
son soutien et sa compassion aux
policiers pour les réactions à des
responsables politiques du département
rendez vous juste après ce journal avec
le 7-8 politique présentée par wilfrid
est riche
le double homicide et à masnières villes
affectées d'autant plus les
fonctionnaires de police et déjà touchés
par l'état d'urgence les attentats de
paris en novembre dernier également par
les violences à leur encontre lors des
dernières manifestations contre le
projet de loi travail
c'est ce que confie loïc travers
secrétaire national adjoint du syndicat
de police alliance nationale
la témoigner au nom au nom du syndicat
son écoeurement et son abattement face à
ce drame il apporte tout son soutien aux
fonctionnaires de police des mureaux
également de mantes-la-jolie nous
l'avons eu en interview par téléphone
aujourd'hui écoutés je crois qu'à
travers ce double à katrina ce sont
toutes les institutions de la république
toute la police nationale qui est
endeuillé tout
et on peut clairement dire aujourd'hui
que rien ne sera plus comme avant à
policier agressé à son domicile
c est un fait nouveau notamment dans le
cadre d'un acte de terrorisme et le
sentiment de tranquillité ou de répit
que les policiers se doit d'avoir
et bien voilà après qu'ils ont effectué
leur dur labeur de deux journées eh bien
elle n'est plus et là il ya quelque
chose de très choquant sur le fait que
ça devient compliqué d'assurer sa propre
défense et surtout celle de sa famille
et ce soir à différents syndicats de
police sont reçus par le ministère de
l'intérieur afin que les fonctionnaires
de police soient tarn et en tout lieu et
en tout temps c'est leur demande ce sera
une décision qui serait prise sur la
base du volontariat les syndicats
demandent qu'elle soit effective même en
dehors de l'état d'urgence et prenons à
présent la dir est prompt à présent la
direction de la ville de plaisir pour
une actualité un petit peu plus légères
les premières maquettes des fresques du
vally bourg ont été dévoilées la
municipalité a profité du festival
escales d'ailleurs ce samedi 11 juin au
château de plaisir pour préciser les
avancées du projet alors pour rappel lui
façade et d'immeubles devrait être
décoré dans ce quartier de 4000
habitants d'ici 2020 découverte des
premiers dessins avec patrick jacques de
dixmude et nicolas landry les presque du
vélib ou prennent forme
trois premières maquettes ont été
présentés lors du festival escales
d'ailleurs deux plaisirs le week-end
dernier les témoignages des habitants du
vally bout ont permis aux artistes de
réaliser ces esquisses des fresques
reflétant la mixité culturelle et
sociale du quartier
il ya trois oeuvres sont présentes
aujourd'hui deux qui sont dans
l'intimité dans l'ain terne
l'une qui parle de l'intimité par
rapport aux gens qui y vivent par
rapport au territoire de plaisir du
grand paris et une autre qui parle de la
poésie la créativité incroyable de ce
quartier là et ensuite on a une offre
qui est extérieur vous verrez qu a pour
objectif d'attirer de manière très
élégante l'attention des gens qui
passeront devant et leur donner envie de
rentrer
ça représente on va dire tout toute
identité toute personne ça va changer
l'image surtout du quartier donné un
certain dynamisme aussi donc que ce soit
au niveau social que ce soit au niveau
économique puisque ça va a tissé on va
dire un certain tourisme
je l'espère derrière ce projet culturel
rentrer dans une perspective globale de
la politique municipale avec notamment
des objectifs sociaux et
environnementaux
c'est une réhabilitation à la fois de
l'habitat aussi au niveau de l'extérieur
pour tout ce qui est bien sûr de du
respect de la planète
et puis le côté reconnaissance
identitaire du quartier non seulement
pour le quartier mais pour l'ensemble de
la ville puisque les fresques seront
tournés vers l'intérieur pour ce côté
cocooning et vers l'extérieur pour que
les plaisirs aux en profite une nouvelle
présentation devrait intervenir en
septembre avant le lancement des travaux
en octobre
la municipalité espère inaugurer la
première fresque avant fin 2016
nous ouvrons une page sports à présent
vous le savez l'équipe d'irlande
s'installe à versailles pendant toute la
durée de l'euro 2016 les veines les
verts s'entraîne au stade mont boron et
séjourne au trianon palace à côté du
château de versailles
des enfants ont eu la chance de les
rencontrer ainsi que l'ambassadrice est
d'irlande dans le cadre d'un programme
scolaire un reportage signé michael et
demi d'euros et fanny bourdillon
l'euro de football c'est également
l'occasion de découvrir de nouvelles
cultures à versailles l'équipe nationale
d'irlande qui séjournent au trianon
palace et s'entraîne au stade mont boron
pendant la compétition a rencontré jeudi
dernier des élèves de l'école carnot de
versailles dans le cadre d'un projet
scolaire des enfants pu interviewer
photographier les joueurs est
l'ambassadrice d'irlande
ils sont curieux mais ils ont tout aussi
superbe yens informés au sujet violent
tout à l'heure il m'en parlait de 200
patrick de l'irlande lille vers de la
merde violent donc ils sont très bien
enfants mais les enfants j'ai préparé
connaissez-vous quand un drame c'est
donc le chef de l'hôtel
tiens j'ai dit est ce que est ce que les
installations sportives
clcv au total une quinzaine d'élèves ont
rencontré les sportifs dans les salons
du trianon
c'est vraiment sympa comme je croyais
qu'ils à lire un pouvoir faire leur star
mais pas du tout ils sont vraiment super
qu'il faut
ce master n'est fait beau jour de ma vie
parce que on va tous les pouvoirs des
joueurs de foot d'être célèbre c'est
leur entraînement et et après l'autre et
un palace c'est sur cette purge de radis
des joueurs étaient très très gentil
avec les jeunes il était ravi de
rencontrer les jeunes français surtout
mais pour eux ça manque quelques par
l'accueil chaleureux qu'ils versailles
aujourd'hui les irlandais resteront à
versailles au minimum jusqu'au 23 juin
et la fin des phases de poules
d'autres rencontres avec les enfants
pourraient être programmés si l'irlande
se qualifier en huitièmes de finale
et concernant la russie également
installés dans les yvelines mme à
croissy-sur-seine l'uefa vient
d'annoncer que l'équipe serait
disqualifiée de l'euro si des violences
arrivé dans les stades où l'équipe joue
lors de la rencontre face à l'angleterre
des violences ont éclaté entre
supporters au vélodrome de marseille
mais également dans les rues de la ville
vous avez dû voir les images la russie a
reçu ce sont 50000 euros damende de la
part de l'uefa s'il ya le moindre
incident au stade pierre mauroy de lille
contre la slovaquie au stadium de
toulouse face au pays de galles lors de
la phase de groupes la russie devra
rentrer chez elles se sucent ce sursis
restera en place jusqu'à la fin du
tournoi
à noter que des supporters russes ont
déjà été expulsés de france et france
télévisions au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le journaliste
animateur samuel etienne et son équipe
de france 3 ont tourné ce lundi
notamment avec jérémy rencurel un espoir
du bmx une séquence de sur les terres à
des champions une émission de 52 minutes
pour découvrir les athlètes français
sélectionnés pour les jo de rio elle
sera diffusé fin juillet sur la chaîne
publique
comme vous pouvez le voir sur ces images
il était tôt micro de michael et demi
d'euros et nicolas d'andré mais l'idée
c'est d'abord de comprendre les
difficultés du sport alors la gelée
compris très concrètement toutes ces
bosses
et puis de faire comprendre aux
téléspectateurs ce qu'est vraiment un
champion moi j'adore le sport le sport a
pris ces dernières années ces quinze
dernières années énormément d'importance
dans ma vie la course à pied d'abord
l'endurance d'une manière générale j'ai
découvert le triathlon il ya deux ans je
fais beaucoup de sport mais comme un
amateur et ç'a pris une part importante
des mutants ma vie parce que ça
m'apporte énormément humainement ça me
change les idées d'abord on est dans les
métiers parfois un peu stressant et puis
ça me donne de l'endurance tout ça me
permet de tenir le coup un peu plus
longtemps en plateau par exemple et
passons maintenant un tout autre sujet
l'été arrive c'est le moment de trouver
un job d'été pour les étudiants afin de
financer leurs études ou pourquoi pas
leurs vacances pourquoi ne pas utiliser
allier l'utile à l'agréable avec la
brochette c'est l'emblème de l'été
l'enseigne nouveau viande en produit
plus d'un million d'avril à septembre
pour les réaliser elle recherche
actuellement une centaine de
collaborateurs en ile de france nous
sommes allés découvrir le travail de
brewster un job d'été accessible à tous
les âges des atouts mais tous les jeunes
pardon dès l'âge de 16 ans camille
lambert pour ce reportage au boeuf ou au
poulet la brochette et l'incontournable
des barbecues de l'été steve elle a 19
ans et depuis début mai il en prépare
plusieurs centaines par jour
un emploi estival qui lui permet de
financer ses études de kinésithérapie
matin je commence à 6 heures lève à 5h
je viens ici je
coupe des poivrons la viande déjà prête
par les bouchers et après j'ai que a
enfilé toute la journée les brochettes
ça me plaît enfin je suis très content
au début au début ça me paraissait un
petit peu dur et au final on s'habitue
vite et le rythme et il se prend il se
prend facilement six morceaux de légumes
pour cinq morceaux de viande un poids
compris entre 180 et 220 g la brochette
est parfaitement calibré plus d'un
million sont réalisés par l'enseigne
d'avril à septembre en de france nouveau
vient de recherche une centaine de
collaborateurs comme stivell un contrat
à temps partiel pouvant devenir à temps
plein en fonction de la météo qu'on
travaille en partenariat avec météo
france
on a reçoit la météo tous les jours tous
les matins et donc en fonction de la
météo on appelle nos gros shooteur
actuellement dans le secteur de daisy
vie nous recherchons une vingtaine de
brewster
donc si vous êtes motivés vous êtes
jeanne disponibles vous pouvez postuler
la vente de brochettes représentent 20%
du chiffre d'affaires de nouveaux viande
rémunérés au smic le métier de brewster
a été breveté par l'enseigne selon un
sondage réalisé par opinionway en 2014
75 % des français déclarent pratiquer le
barbecue les brochettes sont prêtes
il ne reste plus qu'à les déguster et
attendre le retour du soleil éducation à
présent jeudi 9 juin une cinquantaine
élèves de terminale section européenne
du lycée hôtelier de guyancourt reçu
leur europass lors d'une cérémonie
une manière de conclure leur formation
de trois ans alors leur passe valide
leur stage à l'étranger effectuées en
2015 une expérience professionnelle de 2
mois réalisées au sein l'établissement
reconnu en irlande en écosse où
notamment en estonie dans des hôtels et
des bases de 4 ou 5 étoiles la filière
section européenne permet de
sensibiliser les jeunes à la citoyenneté
européenne de renforcer lors anglais et
de devenir plus autonomes on écoute les
réactions des professeurs mais aussi des
élèves
ça clôt l'année scolaire ce n'est pas
diplômant mais c'est juste une
valorisation
de leur expérience professionnelle c'est
un moment fort de leur scolarité
c'est un moment c'est un moment où on se
retrouve on va fêter quelque chose d'un
peu de collaboratif d'agréable ça permet
pas d'avoir la réussite d'avoir accompli
parce qu'on a fait pendant ces trois ans
donc je ris que ben hassine une belle
concrétisation
c'est formidable et ça fait trois ans
que je suis ici j'ai appris beaucoup de
choses j'ai fait
un stage à l'étranger donc c'est super
bien passé et j'ai fait plusieurs stages
en france qui sont superbes la
possibilité là il est temps à présent de
passer à notre entretien le 22 juin
c'est la journée nationale sur réflexion
du don et de la greffe d'organes
pour nous en parler en plateau avec nous
ce soir cécile hamas prend on soin
ravoux lanceur alors vous êtes
infirmière coordinatrice à l'hôtel de
versailles notamment sur le don
d'organes alors parlez nous de cette
journée cette journée du 22 juin qu'elle
est un petit peu le but alors la journée
du 22 juin elle est à l'initiative de l'
agence de la biomédecine qui est un
organe d'état qui gère tout ce qui est
don et greffe en france le but c'est
sensibiliser les gens
on fait qu'il faut parler de son choix
d'honneur ou pas si on souhaite donner
ou pas ses organes après sa mort
l'important c'est de le dire à ses
proches et cette journée elle permet au
grand public d'avoir un maximum
d'information sur le don d'organes pour
qu'ils puissent faire leur choix et en
parler à leurs proches
alors justement il faut qu'on explique
un petit peu comme on se déclare
d'honneur parce qu'au début tout le
monde est donneur d'organes il faut se
signifier pour ne pas justement donner
ses organes c'est un petit peu compliqué
à comprendre oui voilà alors en fait il
y a
deux façons
de donner ses organes il ya les donneurs
du vivant est donc là c'est une démarche
active où il faut se déclarer d'honneur
auprès d'une personne qui est en attente
de greffe c'est quelqu'un qu'on connaît
et puis il ya les donneurs après le
décès et ça c'est 80 % des graisses en
france sont fait suite à des donneurs
décédés
hélas la doua la loi dit qu'on est tous
donneurs présumé en france sauf si on
s'y est opposé de son vivant pour s'y
opposer il ya deux façons de le faire
le registre national des refus qui est
gérée par l' agence de la biomédecine
auquel faut aller s'y inscrire si on ne
souhaite pas donner ses organes après sa
mort est la deuxième façon c'est d'en
parler à ses proches de dire à ses
proches
quand je serai mort je ne souhaite pas
donner mes organes vous voyez à l'image
donc la carte de donneur d'organes n'a
pas de valeur officielle
c'est ça la cale à la carte de donneur
d'organes n'a pas de valeur légale
elle nous donne elle nous permet de
d'entamer la discussion avec les proches
puisque s'il arrive quelque chose à
quelqu'un on va aller voir ses proches
pour savoir s'il était d'honneur ou pas
d'organe mois l'infirmière coordinatrice
et le médecin réanimateur et quand on
retrouve une carte de don d'organes dans
le portefeuille ça nous donne un petit
peu de ça nous permet d'être un levier
pour pour entamer la discussion
voilà donc finalement les modalités à
remplir c'est simplement par l'asa
payant pas ses proches
c'est la chose la plus importante à
faire si on souhaite donner ses organes
c'est d'en parler à ses proches
alors comme pour le don du sang est ce
que vous avez voilà besoin de d'un
certain nombre de dons par an par mois
quels sont les besoins en france en
france au 1er juin 2016 il y avait plus
de 13000 personnes en attente de dons
d'organes tout organe rofo du et en 2015
on a pu faire plus un petit peu plus de
5700 greffe ce chiffre ne cesse
d'augmenter tous les ans mais en
parallèle la liste d'attentes d'organes
augmentent plus vite que
le que les dons qu'on fait par an
sachant que le nombre de donneurs tous
ne sont pas prélevés c'est un sur deux
c'est ça alors
encore une fois il ya les deux sortes de
donneurs 80 % des donneurs sont des
donneurs décédés
c'est une mort qui est un petit peu
particulière c'est la mort encéphalique
c'est à dire que le cerveau est détruit
mais que le coeur continue à battre la
personne est bien décédé est donc sûre
chez ces morts encéphaliques c'est
seulement un pour cent des décès en
france donc c'est une mort très
particulière et chez ces patients en
état de mort encéphalique
on ne prélève que la moitié de ces
personnes seulement se la moitié de ces
personnes peuvent faire un don d'organes
pour différentes raisons mais notamment
aussi parce qu'on retrouve une opère une
opposition des proches parce qu'ils ne
connaissent pas la volonté du la
personne défunte
alors on l'a vu avec les attentats de
paris en novembre dernier eut beaucoup
de donneurs de sang qui sont manifestés
on voit là volontairement
est ce qu'il ya eu le même effet pour
justement les dons d'organes ya le plus
de gentilles ont signifié voilà qu'il
voulait qu'ils acceptaient à leur
famille vous avez ressenti c'est ce
phénomène
il n'y a pas eu vraiment de deux
phénomènes de vague de demandes plus de
d'information ou de carte de donneur par
rapport aux attentes assez assez moins
significatif parce que suite aux
attentats il ya les personnes blessées
qui avait besoin de sang mêlé personne
blessée elle n'avait pas besoin
d'organes à l'instant t
donc ya pas eu cet effet boomerang alors
le 22 janv vous organisez une des
initiatives donc sur tout le territoire
notamment le thème de verseilles comment
ça se passait c'est une journée
d'information c'est ça oui alors à
l'hôpital de versailles le 22 juin entre
9 heures et 17 heures on tiendra un
stand d'information
l'équipe de la coordination hospitalière
qui est ouvert bien sûr au grand public
toutes les personnes qui viendront
visiter une personne malade ou qui
viendront en consultation d'hôpital de
versailles peuvent s'arrêter à notre
stand et puis on leur donnera les
informations qu'il le souhaite leur
donner les modalités pour s'inscrire sur
le registre national des refus s'ils le
souhaitent ou leur fournir une carte de
don d'organes 6e même son honneur est ce
que vous sentez que
sujet a évolué que c'est peut-être moins
tabou de le don d'organes en france ou
que ça reste comme compliqué ça reste
est abordé avec ça reste un sujet
difficile parce qu'on parle de la mort
et donc ça en france ça reste quelque
chose un peu tabou les gens disent pas
quand je serai mort je voudrais je
souhaiterais donner mes organes où je
souhaiterais être enterré incinérés
c'est quelque chose qu'on en parle
difficilement entre au sein de la
famille cependant on trouve quand même
il ya quand même une évolution par
rapport à ça et notamment avec les
jeunes générations qui sont tout à fait
ouvert à la discussion
et voilà qu'ils cherchent un maximum
d'informations vous allez essayer
justement d'en parler avec les lycéens
et les collégiens même si la c1 sur i
télé comme sensibles ont fait une fait
de l'information dans les collèges et
les lycées des environs à partir de la
troisième parce que pour s'inscrire fin
pourra l'être pour le registre national
des refus on peut aller s'y inscrire à
partir de l'âge de 13 ans et pour nous
c'est important que les jeunes soient
informés sur ce sujet pour qu'il puisse
prendre une décision en toute
connaissance de cause alors une dernière
question avant de terminer cet entretien
la situation dans les yvelines à ce
qu'il ya des inégalités territoriales
est ce que les aînés est un un
département où voilà où il ya plus ou
moins de dons d'organes
il n'y a pas moins de dons d'organes en
ile-de-france ont un taux de refus
qu'est un petit peu plus élevé que dans
le reste de la france
en france il ya 33 % de refus 1 c1 c'est
un chiffre qui est assez important en
ile de france on est pas loin des 37 %
et messieurs c'est surtout les gens qui
sont en attente
en ile de france quand on est en attente
d'un organe l'attenté plus longue
lorsqu'on habite en ile-de-france que
lorsqu'on habite dans le reste de la
france merci beaucoup c'est cinéma ce
programme yeux sur notre plateau et nous
avoir répondu à nos questions lors pour
plus d'informations n'hésitez pas à vous
rendre sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran je le
rappelle la journée nationale sur la
réflexion et la greffe du don d'organes
c'est le 22 juin dans toute la france
merci à vous et nous continuons à parler
santé aujourd'hui c'est la journée
mondiale des donneurs de sang le fs
organisée après occasions différentes
initiatives et ce mardi 14 juin
une collecte a eu lieu à l'hôtel de
ville d'elancourt plus d'une
cinquantaine de personnes se sont
déplacées pour l'occasion le ffs avait
lancé le 2 juin dernier un appel
d'urgence en prévision des besoins pour
cet été mais aussi en raison de l'euro
2016 à l'établissement français du sang
a besoin de dix mille 12 journalier
chaque année ce sont un million de
patients qui sont soignés grâce aux
collectes écoutez les réactions
recueillies sur place par camille
lambert bas il est certain qu on a
toujours besoin de produits sanguins
quand même des maladies qui qui se
soigne uniquement avec des produits
sanguins n'a pas d'autre solution pour
les personnes condamnées me et personnes
qui sont opérés personnes pour un
déficit congénitales en facteur de
coagulation on à clé produit sanguin
il ya tellement de gens qui ont besoin
de sens pour les opérations pour
participer aux nécessités qui a un sens
pour ceux qui en ont besoin au moment où
je peux moi me permettre de donner et
pour terminer à ce journal prenons la
direction de bois d'arcy samedi dernier
la commune organisée à la ferme du
tremblay la fête de la nature
au programme de la journée ateliers de
greffage d'arbres aux bourses aux
plantes ou encore jeu de l'oie géant sur
le thème est des déchets un reportage
signé y est c'est le moal et patrick à
jacques de dixmude à découvrir ou
redécouvrir les richesses naturelles de
sa région et savoir en prendre soin
c'était l'objectif de la seconde édition
de la fête de la nature
elle s'est tenue samedi 11 juin à bois
d'arcy une manifestation initiée depuis
2015 par les jeunes de la ville c'est
les jeunes du conseil municipal qui ont
décidé en fait de mettre en place cette
fête de la nature ça fait longtemps
qu'ils en parlent ils avaient vraiment à
coeur de faire de mettre en place un
vrai projet en sur l'environnement
bourse aux plantes ateliers et
animations
une douzaine de stands étaient proposés
les visiteurs ont pu notamment s'initier
à la réalisation d'une greffe ou encore
donner une deuxième vie à des objets
inutilisés ou a rejeté dans la nature
on essaye à un petit peu de mettre en
garde les personnes effectivement de
faire attention et de montrer par
diverses divers stands qui sont ici
présents que voilà il faut y faire
attention et on a tous la possibilité à
notre niveau de faire quelque chose
après avoir diffusé en 2015
le film home cette année c'est son
réalisateur yann arthus bertrand qui a
été invité il est venu tenir une
conférence sur le thème de la nature et
du développement durable quand on parle
environnement pense souvent à ces films
qui sont vraiment avant gardiste parce
que c'était vraiment un des premiers à
avoir fait à grande échelle au niveau de
la planète
des mises en garde très important près
de 500 personnes sont venues fêter la
nature une journée clôturée par une
soirée de concerts face à ce succès une
troisième édition est déjà envisagée et
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis rester avec nous tout
de suite vous retrouvez wilfried errishi
pour le 7-8 politique il sera notamment
question des attentats de magnanville de
magnanville pardon il reviendra avec les
différentes réactions des personnalités
politiques du département quant à moi je
vous retrouve demain pour une nouvelle
édition du journal je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée